Imagine driving down the highway at like 65 miles an hour.
Okay. Sounds pretty standard.
Right. You are seamlessly changing lanes, you're obeying the traffic lights, using your turn
signals, and just perfectly navigating complex interstate exits.
Yeah. Totally running on autopilot.
Exactly. But here's the catch. You have absolutely no idea who you are, where you came from,
or where you're going.
Oh, wow. That is terrifying.
Right. Your mind has completely wiped your identity, your history, your personal connections.
But it kept the procedural stuff online.
Exactly. It kept your motor skills and your ability to navigate the physical world fully intact.
I mean, the outward behavior in a scenario like that, it appears entirely functional
and deliberate to anyone watching.
Yeah, nobody driving next to you would even know.
But the internal system, the actual neurological architecture, has basically enacted this
radical emergency quarantine of the person's core identity, just to keep the organism moving.
Which brings us to our topic. Welcome to the deep tide.
Glad to be here.
Our mission today for you listening is to unpack this dense, super complex,
but genuinely astonishing set of clinical prep notes regarding dissociative disorders.
They are fascinating notes.
They really are. These sources give us a granular look at how the human mind bends,
how it actively fragments itself, and how it deploys these radical protective measures
under conditions of extreme inescapable stress.
And treating these clinical notes merely as a list of diagnostic criteria,
it really misses the broader reality of what we're looking at here.
Yeah, it's not just a checklist.
No, not at all. We are examining a biological map of human survival.
A survival map. I like that.
Because when an environment becomes fundamentally unsurvivable, particularly early in life,
the mind engineers a way to survive the unsurvivable.
By altering its own foundational operating system.
Exactly.
Okay, so let's unpack this. Before we dive into the specific clinical codes,
our sources establish a baseline definition of dissociation.
Right. The core concept.
Yeah. They define it as a disruption in the, quote,
normally smooth flow of identity, memory, and awareness.
That phrase, the smooth flow, is so crucial.
It really stands out.
We totally take for granted that the brain acts as this invisible master conductor.
Synchronizing millions of parallel processes.
Right, into a single unified sense of self.
Like you wake up, you carry the memories of yesterday,
and you experience your environment in real time as a singular cohesive entity.
And that synchronization requires massive continuous neurological coordination.
I mean, the default mode network, the hippocampus, the prefrontal cortex.
They're all working overtime.
They are constantly stitching sensory input and memory together.
So dissociation is the active disruption of that stitching process.
The brain just stops integrating the data.
Precisely.
So what does this all mean practically?
The notes provide this overarching anchor for this entire deep dive.
The reality testing concept.
Yes, in all of these dissociative disorders, reality testing stays intact.
Which is such an important distinction.
Let me test an analogy on you here.
So if intact reality testing is like sitting in a movie theater
where the film suddenly starts skipping,
where the audio completely de-syncs from the video.
Okay, I'm picturing it.
It feels incredibly disorienting.
Right.
But you still fundamentally know you are just a person sitting in a theater watching a broken
movie.
You haven't lost the awareness of the theater itself.
Right.
That gets us halfway there, actually.
But let's push that analogy further to really understand the clinical distress involved.
Okay, push it further.
How so?
It is not just that you know you are in a theater watching a corrupted film.
It's that the doors to the theater are locked from the outside.
Oh, man.
That's claustrophobic.
Exactly.
You are painfully aware that the movie is glitching.
You're fully conscious that the experience is distorted.
But you also know you cannot fix the projector.
You're just trapped watching the glitch.
Right.
The distress and dissociation comes from that exact awareness.
You are anchored to base reality enough to know your internal reality is malfunctioning.
That locked door element transforms it from just a weird experience into a genuinely terrifying one.
It really does.
And that distinction, the intact reality testing, that is exactly what separates
a dissociative disorder from a psychotic break.
Exactly.
Because in psychosis, the person doesn't know the movie is broken.
They believe the movie is reality.
Right.
In a psychotic state, the theater basically vanishes.
The person might believe they've been physically transported into the film.
Or that the distorted audio is like a secret message sent directly to them.
Precisely.
Reality testing fails completely there.
But with dissociation, the foundational awareness that something is wrong remains online.
Which is why these patients often present with immense anxiety about their own mental space.
They know something is off and it's terrifying.
So we have a foundational understanding of the smooth flow breaking
and the crucial anchor of reality testing staying intact.
Let's follow the narrative logic of this defense mechanism.
Where does it break first?
Yeah, what happens when the smooth flow breaks at the absolute highest level,
like the level of identity?
Well, that brings us to dissociative identity disorder,
which is clinically coded in the notes as F44.81.
F44.81.
Okay.
The sources characterize DD by the presence of two or more distinct personality states.
Accompanied by recurrent gaps in memory for everyday events.
Right, and personal information.
Since we're looking at this beyond just surface level symptoms,
let's look at the actual mechanism.
Let's do it.
The notes classify ordinary forgetting as a simple retrieval failure.
You know, you just misplace your keys.
Standard glitch.
Yeah.
But DD memory gaps are entirely different.
How does the brain actively wall off complete neural pathways,
like entire compartments of consciousness,
while keeping others perfectly accessible?
We basically have to look at state dependent memory
taken to an absolute structural extreme.
State dependent memory.
Yeah, so memory encoding is deeply tied to our physiological state.
When a child experiences severe repeated trauma,
which the sources explicitly highlight as the root cause of DD,
the amygdala triggers an overwhelming flood of stress hormone.
Just a massive chemical dump.
Right.
The brain learns that to survive this catastrophic hyperarousal,
it must segregate the memories, the skills,
and the emotional responses associated with the trauma
from the neural networks used for daily functioning.
It builds firewalls.
It creates distinct encapsulated states of consciousness.
Yes.
Wow.
One identity state holds the trauma,
absorbing the unbearable emotional load,
while another identity state remains completely amnesic to that trauma.
So the child can literally still walk into a classroom and learn math.
Exactly.
It is an extraordinary feat of neurological load distribution.
Which makes the treatment protocol outlined in our sources
incredibly challenging, I'd imagine.
Oh, absolutely.
The first line treatment for DD is phase oriented trauma psychotherapy.
And here's where it gets really interesting for your listeners.
The specific phasing.
Yeah.
The notes dictate that the very first phase is always safety and stabilization.
Without exception.
But honestly, playing devil's advocate here,
that seems somewhat counterintuitive.
How so?
Well, if the repressed trauma is the root cause of the entire disorder,
wouldn't delaying the trauma processing just prolong the patient's suffering?
Like, why are clinicians instructed to hold off on digging into the root cause?
What's fascinating here is the biological reality of the nervous system.
The trauma we are discussing isn't a physical wound where you just go in,
extract the bullet, and stitch it up.
Right.
It's not a surgical extraction.
No.
To the patient's nervous system, the trauma is an ever-present environmental absolute.
The danger is still right now for them.
Exactly.
If a clinician bypasses stabilization and immediately tries to unpack the traumatic
memories, they are forcing the brain to access networks.
It's specifically walled off because they were lethal to the system's stability.
Oh, so you would throw them entirely outside their window of tolerance.
They would enter a state of extreme autonomic hyperarousal.
You wouldn't be healing the trauma at all.
You'd just be re-traumatizing them.
Yes.
You would be proving to the brain that its environment is still fundamentally unsafe.
And what happens when the brain feels that level of overwhelming threat?
Its only programmed response is to deploy its ultimate defense mechanism again.
You risk forcing the identity to fragment even further.
Wow.
So you could actively make the DID worse.
Precisely.
Establishing absolute safety and stabilization isn't just prep work.
It is actively rewiring the nervous system to realize the war is over.
Which is the prerequisite for any memory integration later.
Right.
You can't process the past if your body thinks you're still fighting for your life in the present.
Okay, so we see the brain fracture the self to distribute the load.
That's DID.
Right.
But what happens when the brain decides not to fragment the identity,
but instead just like pulls the plug on the hard drive entirely?
Ah, that shifts us to the F44.0 clinical code.
Dissociative amnesia.
The notes define dissociative amnesia as the inability to recall important personal information,
usually surrounding a traumatic or stressful event.
Right, the data is just inaccessible.
But the most extreme manifestation of this, and arguably one of the most baffling phenomena
in all of clinical psychology, is when this amnesia is accompanied by a fugue.
The fugue state, yes.
This is where the neurological separation becomes physically kinetic.
Kinetic, right.
The sources describe the fugue state as purposeful travel or wandering,
combined with amnesia for one's own identity.
This brings us back to that highway scenario we opened the deep dive with.
Exactly.
The brain's GPS has completely wiped its destination history.
It deleted the home address.
It erased the driver's profile.
But the engine is running, and the car is navigating traffic flawlessly.
How does the brain manage to keep procedural memory,
like buying a bus ticket, driving a car, ordering food completely online,
while episodic memory, who I am and where I live, goes completely dark?
It comes down to selective retrieval.
What makes that functional separation possible is the brain's ability to
selectively disable episodic retrieval without touching the motor or procedural centers at all.
Because they live in different parts of the brain.
Exactly.
Procedural memory is deeply ingrained in areas like the basal ganglia and the cerebellum.
Okay.
Episodic memory, the actual narrative of you, relies heavily on the hippocampus.
Right. The story of my life is hippocampal.
Yes.
So during a fugue state, the massive surge of stress hormones
effectively suppresses hippocampal function, blocking access to biographical data.
But the basal ganglia just keeps firing away.
It sure does.
Because survival requires mobility.
The brain basically says, I don't know who we are,
but we have to leave this geographic location immediately.
It is the ultimate flight response.
The ultimate flight response. Wow.
The organism physically removes itself from the environment associated with the unendurable
stress, utilizing all its procedural skills to do so.
While protecting the conscious mind from the trauma by just erasing the self.
It's an incredible, albeit extreme, adaptation.
Looking at the treatment for this, our notes emphasize establishing safety again.
But they add a highly specific caveat for dissociative amnesia.
The pacing of memory retrieval.
Yeah. The goal of supportive psychotherapy is letting the memory return at a tolerable pace.
This raises an important question, actually.
Right. Because in other trauma or anxiety treatments, like, say,
exposure therapy for severe phobias, collisions sometimes use flooding
to rapidly recalibrate the brain.
They throw you right into the deep end.
Exactly. Why can't you just show a fugue patient their driver's license,
bring their family into the room, and force the system to reboot?
We really have to distinguish between a learned fear and a structural defense here.
Okay. Unpack that.
Flooding a phobia works by triggering a false alarm
and letting the nervous system realize there is no actual danger.
Right. The spider isn't going to kill you.
Exactly. But dissociative amnesia isn't a false alarm. It is a load-bearing wall.
A load-bearing wall?
Yes. The amnesia is actively suppressing a physiological overload of cortisol and adrenaline.
Oh, so the danger is the internal chemical flood.
Right. If you forcefully tear that wall down by confronting them with undeniable
proof of their identity and trauma before they have coping mechanisms in place.
It would be too much.
Their resulting physiological shock could be catastrophic.
The structural integrity of the mind basically collapses.
Exactly. The memory has to be coaxed back online.
Titrated.
Yes. The clinician must titrate the exposure to the past
so the nervous system can slowly metabolize the emotional weight.
Without tripping the emergency shutoff switch again.
Precisely. You don't want to trigger another fugue.
So the brain can fracture the self into distinct states
and it can wipe the episodic hard drive entirely.
Right.
But what happens when the brain can't do either of those things?
Like, what happens when the stress is overwhelming?
But the mind is forced to remain fully conscious, fully yourself,
with all memories perfectly intact.
Well, then the brain is forced to alter the actual perception of reality itself.
Which brings us to depersonalization-derealization disorder.
It does.
And I really want to pause on the clinical coding here for a second
because there is a very deliberate shift in our sources.
The shift from F44 to F48.
Exactly. Dissociative identity disorder and dissociative amnesia
were both in the F44 cluster.
But depersonalization-derealization disorder is coded as F48.1.
Why the separate classification?
The F44 cluster specifically categorizes dissociative amnesias and identity alterations.
Situations where data is either missing or partitioned off.
Right. The F48 cluster covers other nonpsychotic disorders
with a focus on somatic or perceptual distortions.
Perceptual distortions.
Yes. In DPDR, the memory and identity data are perfectly intact.
You know exactly who you are and what happened.
Okay.
What is disrupted is the sensory data processing.
The emotional tagging of the incoming information is basically interceptive.
Intercepted. The sources break this perceptual distortion into two distinct experiences, right?
Let's map these out.
Let's do it.
First up, depersonalization.
The notes describe this as feeling like an outside observer of your own body
or your own thoughts.
Right. This self feels alien.
Yeah. They modernize the analogy.
It's like being forced into third-person mode in a video game.
That is a perfect way to describe it.
Normally, human consciousness is strictly first-person.
You look out of your own eyes, you feel your own hands moving,
but depersonalization pulls the camera back.
You feel disconnected.
Yeah. You feel like you are floating behind or above yourself, watching your body talk,
watching your hands move, but feeling completely disconnected from the physical avatar you are
controlling.
The neurological mechanism behind this is just fascinating.
Research suggests the brain is actively dampening the emotional resonance of sensory input.
Dampening it.
Like turning down the volume.
Basically.
Areas like the anterior cingulate cortex may be heavily down-regulating the amygdala.
The physical sensations of being in a body are still reaching the brain.
You can still feel the cup of coffee in your hand.
But it doesn't feel like my hand.
Right.
The brain strips away the emotional weight that makes those sensations feel inherently yours.
You're left with this hollow mechanical awareness of your own existence.
The mechanical awareness.
Yeah.
Wow.
And then there's the second half of this code, which is derealization.
If depersonalization is a detachment from the self,
derealization is a detachment from the world.
The environment itself.
Yeah.
The sources say the environment feels unreal, distant, or dreamlike.
It is as if someone dropped a pane of thick, foggy glass between you and the rest of the
universe.
Or suddenly replaced the physical world with a cardboard movie set.
A cardboard set, yes.
The visual and auditory processing centers are functioning.
But again, the depth and the visceral reality are just muted.
It's just flat.
Yeah.
People often report that colors look washed out or that voices sound incredibly far away,
even when the person speaking is standing right next to them.
If we connect this to the bigger picture and loop directly back to our foundational anchor
from the beginning of the show.
The reality testing.
Yes.
This brings us to the agonizing core of depersonalization, derealization disorder.
Throughout this entire experience of feeling completely detached from your own body and
the world around you, your reality testing remains completely undeniably intact.
You know, the world hasn't actually turned to cardboard.
You know, you haven't actually left your physical body.
The true horror of DPDR is the agonizing clarity of knowing your perception is lying to you.
It's the locked theater doors again.
Exactly.
You are fully aware that your sensory processing has been hijacked,
but you cannot force your brain to reattach the emotional weight to reality.
They're just stuck in the glitch.
The treatment for this, unsurprisingly, relies heavily on specialized psychotherapy
aimed at helping the nervous system feel safe enough to lower that perceptual dampening field.
Right.
Essentially teaching the brain that it doesn't need to numb the world to survive it anymore.
It requires grounding techniques, right?
Yes.
Grounding is key to slowly rebuild the neural pathways that connect sensory input
to emotional resonance.
The brain basically has to relearn how to inhabit physical space safely.
We have charted some incredibly complex neurological territory today
across these clinical notes.
We really have covered a lot of ground.
Let's distill the key structural takeaways for you listening.
We looked at the fragmentation of identity with DID code F44.81.
Where the brain compartmentalizes consciousness to endure severe early trauma.
Necessitating a strict clinical focus on safety and stabilization
before any memory integration can even occur.
Then we examined the total suppression of episodic memory in dissociative amnesia code F44.0.
We saw how the brain can initiate a fugue state
relying entirely on procedural memory to physically escape an environment.
All while burying the core identity behind a load-bearing wall
that must be dismantled at a strictly tolerable pace.
And finally, we explore the perceptual distortion of
depersonalization derealization disorder code F48.1.
The third-person detachment from the self and the foggy glass detachment from the world.
And the terrifying clarity of experiencing all of this with perfect intact memory.
Right.
And weaving through all of these codes is the definitive line separating dissociation from psychosis.
Intact reality testing.
No matter how deeply the smooth flow of identity, memory, or awareness is disrupted,
the foundational knowledge that the internal system is malfunctioning remains.
It completely reframes how you look at the architecture of human consciousness.
These aren't just random glitches.
They are highly evolved, deeply complex survival strategies.
Which actually leaves me with a lingering thought
that builds upon the neurobiology we've discussed today.
Something for you to mull over after we finish up.
Oh. I am curious where this leads.
Well, we've established today that dissociation is the mind's extreme defense mechanism.
Like an emergency circuit breaker that disrupts memory and awareness
to shield the organism from the unbearable weight of trauma.
Correct.
Now, imagine the trajectory of neurological medicine.
If science eventually develops a technology, maybe a specialized pharmaceutical
or a precise and neurological procedure
capable of perfectly blocking or erasing specific traumatic memories.
Okay. A selective memory wipe.
Yeah.
Would we essentially be artificially inducing
a controlled localized form of dissociative amnesia?
Wow.
It is a profound philosophical and medical parallel.
You would basically be mimicking the F44.0 mechanism synthetically.
Exactly. It makes you question the boundaries of our clinical classifications.
How so?
Is it possible that what clinical psychology currently codes as disorders?
F44.0 and F44.81 are actually biological blueprints.
Oh. I see where you're going.
Right. If the human brain already possesses the innate architectural design
to purposely hide an unbearable memory behind a firewall to ensure survival,
maybe the clinical disorders we are studying today are just the unrefined,
spontaneous versions of the psychological first aid of tomorrow.
It implies that in these dissociative states, the mind isn't really broken at all.
No.
It is executing a flawless, albeit extreme,
survival program designed for an unsurvivable world.
The movie projector didn't just break.
It deliberately skipped the scene to stop the film from catching fire.
What a way to put it.
And that is where we will leave you today.
Thank you for joining us on this deep dive.
We will catch you on the next one.